oh
it is early
it looks like we're live
hello everyone good morning um
i woke up early
to play some of the last of his part two
for you guys before work
um obviously this is going to have full
spoilers i am playing from
the very beginning of the game uh for
everyone
who is going to ask i have finished the
game
this is basically my second preview or
second second playthrough sorry
but i am intending to play this very
much real time so i'm going to react to
what i'm doing on screen
uh while you guys are seeing it rather
than
um just talk about the ending because
i'll have plenty of other videos
where i can talk about the rest of the
game so
if you don't want to see the last of us
part two right now
you should stop watching did you stop
you should um
so yeah not not going to discuss too
much about it um not because i'm not
allowed to or anything like that
i just feel like this is a video that i
wanted to make for
people to experience it at the same time
with me and i'm looking forward to this
uh to this playthrough in any case so
let's do it tell me if the audio's off
or anything so i can mix it from the
start because i'll probably leave this
um video live for everyone as they wake
up across the world
it is currently about 5 30 where i am if
i sound very tired
that's why didn't really put
put makeup on just rolled out of bed
made myself a coffee and here i am
um for the record the reason i'm allowed
to stream this now is
i have have had access to it for a few
weeks for coverage purposes but it's out
in new zealand
so shout out to all my friends in new
zealand this is the title screen welcome
new game and let's just go moderate
for the purposes of the stream i don't
want to change any of this
start okay now start
nice looking boat
i actually don't remember exactly how it
starts so
ah yes that's right i thought that was
very pretty but it turns out it's just a
loading screen
this is what the loading screen for the
game looks like
uh i woke up oh
allergy um please save me
last of us part two
i don't know what the loading screen was
for the last one i don't remember
also there aren't very many it's just if
you die really
even then i think it's very very quick
maybe it doesn't even have a loading
screen sometimes it's pretty it's pretty
speedy
thank you sony interactive it is a
naughty dog game you are correct
i do really like the opening too
hey buddy
i don't know what happened
this is a very nice cutscene
i think his hands look really good
do you guys need more volume tell me if
you do
it will be kind of all over the place
though
okay
maybe i just want to do right there
and then we made it
he found the firefight
because of her they were actually going
to make a cure
ishoba he's telling someone
the only catch
he would kill her
sweet jesus doctor what are you doing
i won't let you take her this is our
future think of all the lives we'll save
your very complicated ending
jesus christ joel
what do you do
it's really getting that one spot very
clean
it sure is pretty
comfortable
i do think that the end of the first
game is one of the best video games
it's very good and um
i feel like a lot of this game is about
the consequences of it
a lot of them like different ones from
different people too
god damn
that
that's a lot
where's ellie know i don't know how i'd
react if someone told me that
i told her they just ran some tests
i told her her immunity meant
nothing
and she believed you
it's a good opening i really think it is
i didn't say otherwise
we should head back
i want to pay more attention to the
sound this time around to the soundtrack
the sound design in this game is
phenomenal about
the music specifically
oh boy
everybody's dead
and i'm now in control for the record um
i feel like the transition between
gameplay and cutscenes is not always
like that but
in um a lot of cases really seamless
oh goanna or something just run up that
tree is that a really australian thing
that you see
it's also just super lush really nice
lighting
yeah look at that
this is a nice way to spend my 5 30 am
today i was holding it the whole time
come on
i'm gonna slow down anyway show you guys
here's how everything looks
i feel like the horses look really good
too hey joel
i love you buddy i really do
he's got an arthur morgan jacket on
dad's in there tan coats
big dad energy
yeah the music in the section is really
nice
and i feel like the game does really
often
jump between having some really nice
pleasant moments and dark [ __ ]
i love this looks like a postcard or
a movie poster probably more accurately
just the way these two specifically look
pretty
mm-hmm
like you could see the detail of them
having like logged out here because
obviously they would need to do that to
build the fences
pay attention to that last time
hello thank you
hi jacksonville
come on it's okay i got him you going
you sure
all right all right
about what we were talking about earlier
i can't say i'd have done different
i don't know man i'll take it to the
grave if i have to
it's pretty messed up
i don't really know either though that's
i think like what made
the last of us won that ending so
interesting is you completely understand
why he did it
you also completely understand why it
was the wrong thing to do
why it isn't necessarily what you would
have done um
yeah it makes you really have to think
about it once when it's all done
still cutscenes so far uh yeah i write a
horse for a bit
but that's about it
hello
early look at this nice awkward dad
yeah eric i think the graphics are
pretty damn good especially human faces
listen it's no hell ain't noise they're
just really good
dragon set out new zealand what about
that crap sony and andy said about it
at the same time it is at the same time
time zones ma'am hey
hey
what's up joel cute awkward interaction
just checking in
folks are you know talking about how
impressed they are with
you and how well you're
helping out
i love this yeah
tommy and i went out riding the other
day and
he uh
they told me a joke and i i thought
about you it's um
oh shooting i forgot it i just love the
awkward dad energy i just think it's
so sweet it's uh
it's pretty late and i gotta get up in a
few hours
yeah i know i'm gonna get out of your
hair just um
i want to show you something just give
me one second
i wish my house what's this stayed in
place when i looked down
damn some folks
call this thing here a guitar
funny
you wanna hear something okay
okay
i think he looks so good promise me
that guitar looks look at all the detail
on it
guitar looks literally real the humans
obviously still don't we're not quite
there yet
the guitar looks
it looks real but i don't know what to
say
no i have to play this okay so
it's that
this does happen a few times you have to
play the guitar
it's odd but cute
if i ever were to lose you
i surely lose
i always think about this to me is a
good singer
when acting and singing do you try to
make yourself a less good singer
cause i can't see
our future days
i've seen a couple of people in the chat
talk about um
someone said it's a shame they
uh ruined this game with the ending or
whatever
i i think i might make a video about it
today i've finished this game
i think people really misunderstand i
think people have seen some things and
have jumped to a conclusion that i just
don't even believe is there
are things that i'm just like
i don't think so i don't think this
game's a 10 out of 10 but
um the the most inaccurate thing i've
seen anyone say is that it disrespects
joel this game is so respectful to joel
and i think everything happens no i
don't know the first thing about it that
i teach you how to play
you did
so what do you say tomorrow night first
life so cute it kills me i can't take it
you bunch of [ __ ] cuties okay nice
watch
okay
i feel like you see him smile as he
turns away
do you remember the joke
um
no joel no last of us too this story is
very much still about joel what is
pretty much the whole thing it's about
joel
the whole game is about joel really
it pays him so much respect everything
everyone does is because of him in my
opinion
that's so dumb
but he is just absolutely her dad at
this point
so he's kind of allowed
it's a good cutscene
there's that droning title
damn you had a rough sleep oh sorry
always laid on my bed
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey this morning sorry i totally
overslept just give me a minute and i'll
get dressed
i heard you had quite a night after i
left
i
she kissed me it was just deena being
dina
she didn't mean anything by it i was
talking about your fight with seth wait
you kissed dina
hmm i thought this was broken up one
week and you make a move on my girl
no she was probably just trying to make
you jealous
i didn't i would never oh
[ __ ] this is awkward i'm messing with
you man
i don't care get dressed
you're the worst i like jesse that's
kind of [ __ ] up you did that
i feel like that's just so
yeah nice smells fine very scripted like
a tv show so i guess this is where ellie
lives
it's bigger than my apartment she's
really rolling in it
can't walk through there apparently your
legs are too wide
to get your jacket and your journal
that's how it works we've been over this
yeah the facial animations are really
really good really really good
sure it's true she doesn't have my
batwing thank you i appreciate your
support
uh yeah i guess there is lots of space
in the apocalypse you're right
you know first place where i didn't
really look at this stuff
she got a bunch of books animals of the
past
little astronaut that's cute painting
stuff
astronomy other planets you know it's
not actually that different to the stuff
i have there's a little arcade cabinet
down there
i guess you'd have really unique kinds
of foods yeah dried seeds and stuff
grains rivoli i don't know what that is
a lot of yeah a lot of seeds man
eating a lot of seeds out here ah but
can you see yourself in the mirror the
ultimate video game test
uh you can
i think it's it's very very pretty
and uh while it looks dirty as hell
and i feel like would be freezing cold
right like i feel like you'd be real
cold in here oh can you see a reflection
in the tv
you can barely but you can
it doesn't quite block out the bed the
way that it should 0 out of 10 naughty
dog failure complete failure
um is joel up yeah probably pretty
chilly
shut up i was just about to get up
i was you got everything
yes
and as all good video games do it starts
in the snow
this morning what
let me see if i got this right you
kissed dina
she kissed me which triggered seth to
call you uh
that's a nice word yep then joel decked
him
more of a push and then you got mad at
joe that part confused me
it was a strange night man i love that
joel's still beating up people for us i
love that relationship so much it's just
so sweet
um yeah i love the way this game
explores that relationship
maria wants a word with you where is she
yeah well i'm busy looking at plants
jesse okay
no clue just tell her you never saw me
nope oh sorry what's your [ __ ]
loyalty
excuse me hey jesse
hey can i hear you hey there's a bit of
a wonky
character model now
got a little ice falling from the roof
hey so we're okay
it's so detailed you and me
yeah of course dina and i are done
i know it's just i don't want you to
does this accent
go in and out i feel like it might we're
cool
thanks i feel like he sometimes sounds
like a little bit southern and sometimes
he doesn't but maybe that who can i talk
who can i talk how can i talk guys
if you're wondering if you can pet the
dog do i have news for you
you can retirement get a good scratch
i'm gonna kill so many of your kind i'm
so sorry but what can i just pat him
again
just to prove to the game that i do in
fact
love a good boy
are you so cute
hey jesse oh hi hi
for the record i don't think i can walk
any faster through this area it really
wants you to look at how detailed
everything is so let's take a look why
not i didn't
hey free parks hell yeah
something rental available what are you
doing forgery i guess oh they're making
horseshoes and i wonder if there are
weapons in there just a blacksmith of
some kind i guess
what do you got tools power tools
i feel like unless you're manufacturing
those somehow those are going to be
expensive
that really is a whole last caucus jesus
a lot of meat
oh yeah people definitely still hunt
hunting so they can get those meats
i don't know why you followed me dude
just let me look at the stuff okay
all right i'm not gonna get lost
so yeah i guess this is where um
ellie and joel live also this is the
sign for the winter dance which is what
happened last night which i believe is
what happened
in the trailer that we saw and ellie
kiss
no good morning justin where's maria in
the back
what kind of alcohol y'all got i haven't
had alcohol in
so long
excuse me ellie there you are come here
seth's got something he wants to say to
you i don't want to hear what that bigot
has to say
do it for me please
fine seth
seth come here i love the way that uh
uh face was animated then hey
uh look last night i was uh
i was drinking too much sure
i'm trying to say i'm sorry
maria tells me that you and dean are
headed out
yeah i made you some sandwiches
so if you've paid attention okay i love
a good
uh snake sandwich sandwich
sandwich i'm so still half asleep um
this guy said something
homophobic because dina kissed ellie the
night before
which resulted in i appreciate that joel
punching him in the face
um which ellie did not like they get
sandwiches
however i do want to mention that's
literally the only reference
you sure to anyone being against them
being gay the whole game
um nobody cares uh
i don't think we're too far off of
meeting dina but they are literally like
just two gay characters and outside of
cutscenes
of course i love the way a backpack i
was gonna check out the creek trails
the i'll need someone else to cover it
individual um ellie
you know the creature is a bismuth
that's cool not really
dina's done it a bunch no they care i'll
have the two of them take
ellie can i talk to you for a sec
yes hello what's up
okay i feel like they're very close to
each other
maria close to you
and i'm sure he didn't mean to fine
yeah yeah okay
okay sorry to pry i think that's cute
too she's defending joel
be safe again thanks if there's anything
the internet is wrong about is that this
game disrespects joel i think it does
the absolutely
oh hey dina can i talk to you
hey guys i'm tapping out come on how
long
how long do you want to play for
hey hey
um i just want to say sorry for running
off last night
oh that's it's okay i totally get it i
i just i felt bad why
because i started the whole thing and
i just i shouldn't have kissed you in
front of all of those people no you were
drunk it's fine
well still i just i don't want you to
think no i'm not reading into it or
anything
just you know really good performances
now you let me finish my sentences
all right well we should probably get
going yeah
ow what the [ __ ] i'm not even playing
because you're a chick
i hate this kid so much you want to [ __ ]
him up
yeah i do you asked for it
such a good performance she's so good
ashley johnson man
gotcha oh that's right i forgot you have
to scoop with triangle and then you
throw it at a kid yeah you better run
this game you're just going to beat up
some kids
oh you like that i think this is like
probably okay
they don't doing me man i wonder what
happens if i lose i didn't try that
um yeah this game is probably just
intended to show you
what what life is generally liking
jacksonville oh what a shot
come on oh
i don't know where that snowball went
check your little jacket back here i'm i
don't even know if this is the right kid
i don't know which kid threw a snowball
at me
where did other kids go i see you
oh there's three of this isn't fair
there's
multiple kids oh my gosh i dodged into
it
and fight you like for real well we're
about to like
like win hard so i know where you live
you know i really just
messed these kids up i see you
like i could be dodging more but you
know ah
not fair eat it shrimps
how's it feel
you'll never get away okay bye i hate
children
i guess they have to help
all right all right we actually have
some work to do
i guess i asked for that huh yep
let's go i just can't stop thinking
about how cold everyone would be
i don't know what time it's supposed to
be i guess ellie woke up but she slept
in he wants us to do the creek
patrol he's gonna maybe not i am so
tommy
oh is there a way i can tell by where
the sun is
no there isn't
morning girls morning good morning sir
i would like to take an equine
on patron thank you look at that
backpack
look at it so good
i just can't ah the start of this game
is stupid detailed
i mean it is consistently but because
this area feels lipton
presently it's different
come on
hey shimmer
that's ellie's whole she called it
shimmer oh not a very cool
pro if you ask me yeah yeah yeah
one for you
and one for you
open it up open it settle down jordan
thank you
all right you all know the drill
run your routes mark your log books
clear any infected you see
you run into anything you can't handle
you come back
be smart about it of course yes
all right get going
so yeah i guess people just um
frequently do patrols in in different
directions
like they said earlier joel is already
out on patrol somewhere because there
was some infected
located somewhere but that's the idea
at that lighting man hot damn
keep making jokes with that guy and neil
druckmann put himself in the game
and here's abby
everyone's favorite
the lighting's so good oh my god naughty
dog
done it again
i feel like i'm very shiny right now
i just put moisturizer on it is the
morning so yes i'm shiny
it's a nice house
hey hey
what were you dreaming about was i
talking
you're doing your teeth grinding this is
uh laura bailey
also very good at what she does where
have you been
grab your gear i want to show you
something
what trust me
come on this way honestly anyone who
lives in an area that's cold can you
give me a guess what the temperature is
i don't know if there's any way that you
can indicate that based on
just it being snowy but i'm sure you
don't want to do it
and it's warmer no
can't wait and you don't want to just
tell me
you need to see it snow tracks look are
they red dead
no not quite not quite red dead
i give this a not quite red dead out of
ten
what are you doing wandering around out
here by yourself
been restless you too
i feel like the farther south we go the
prettier it's gotten
you want to keep going just drive all
the way to mexico
i've thought about it i could see
manny's like it would be more
interesting if they did
yeah i don't see that living up to like
i want to see the last of us australia
what does that look like
i probably didn't need to press x to
jump there you did all this in the door
has embargo been lifted it has yes i
think this is
the first time i've even been allowed to
reference publicly that you play
as another character which includes joel
because obviously i played as joel
earlier
is mel okay but yeah seemed out of it
these past few days
she'll be fine you stop being weird
you're freaking me out
i'm not being weird he thought he was
being weird
are you breaking up with mel what no
you wish uh i've had my phil
thank you ouch
i can't all be as graceful as you
clearly
what is that you'll be fine it's too
high
come on she's she's so panicked
oh my god a face oh hey i don't know if
that was me or you i think that was
scripted
abby stop looking down
no that would be terrifying
oh and do we have to go back this way
consider it an opportunity to work on
your fears
how about i work my foot up your ass
abby
stop flirting
is this one mechanic that i find strange
this one particular mechanic
to push through a wall instead of it
tells you what you have to do
um instead of just being able to go
through it and hold l forward like you
can in
tomb raider which does the same thing
all the time you have to press x every
time
and i don't know why
you know having finished this game and
even playing it now
i'm always like why can't i just press
alpha why do i have to press x
i just don't i don't know why they did
that this is it
we made it holy [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] city yeah
i'm a town agree to disagree
have you told anyone else i wanted you
to see it first
i saw an arm patrol go from town to an
outpost over there
a few more outposts in between
they have electricity guns
so yeah you're basically getting a lot
of people outsiders perspective on we
can figure it out
on jacksonville okay
assuming he's in there how do we get to
him
we can corner one of the patrols and get
confirmation and then
i don't know maybe find a way to lure
them out
yeah okay i'm sure they'll be happy to
offer that information
well then we make them
you hear yourself
okay i guess the reason he's being so
awkward is because he's showing her just
how legit jacksonville is and how
difficult it's going to be to
what is going on lure someone out
mel's pregnant
oh okay
it's not just that though should i say
congrats and everyone else sees this
they're gonna want to turn back
we can convince them great
i [ __ ] knew i couldn't count on you
happy
i want what you want he's pretty
intimidating not at any cost
if y'all rolled in there you don't die
don't
i get it
why do you have to play as the villains
breakups um
i think this game is very much about
who are the villains um
i don't want to say anything more but it
is very well justified uh
it completely makes sense to me and i
feel like it'll make sense to people who
play it i feel like it hasn't made sense
to
the angry portion of the internet but i
feel like in a week they'll be like oh i
get
that perspective because you have all
this game plus gameplay
playing as different characters does
make sense
um
did you think joel was gonna do what he
did in the first game and uh
and not have any consequences at all
when he could have saved
[ __ ] everyone coming up
oh gosh uh i don't know where i'm
supposed to go
up here
ah windows defender did not find any
threats since my last summary
thank you pc i'm glad to hear that
why did you tell me that at 6 00 am or
whatever the [ __ ] the time is are we
going up
maybe yes yes
this seems wrong but
i guess it's right i actually do
get stumped in terms of environments
like semi-frequently when playing this
um i'm bad at navigating in general
that's that's on me
but uh get down
i feel like it might also be intentional
that it's not always immediately clear
where you are supposed to go i mean
lighting and then the way thing the
level design literally does direct
you towards certain pathways but um i
feel like
it makes sense that the characters don't
always know where to go either pregnant
yeah you know people be boning out
[ __ ] in the apocalypse man it happens
oh you are quite frozen
you alive
did you really think he was alive
come on now
let the bodies hit the floor again i
have to press x every time
i just don't know why ah you think it's
minus 35
c that's the coldest i've ever been in
and it was in canada
wait the game's still set to minecraft
dungeons on youtube i always have to
update it like three times
yeah i have to update it once i update
it on free stream then i have to update
it on youtube every time that i'm live
it's super weird let me uh
fix that real quick hopefully it sticks
because it
never does um
yes i am going to leave this stream up i
don't know how long i'll stream fall
we'll kind of i'll kind of feel it out
because like obviously it's really early
for me here i woke up
at 5 30 to do this for you guys
um i thought i would get it in before
work starts so yeah we'll see
more options
i don't know why it never updates it's
so strange the
last of us part two
there we go save
hopefully that updates
don't know why it does it okay yeah
minecraft
minecraft dungeons that that ray tracing
really hit different
okay
dude
um some other weapon halo
we're just gonna go it is actually cool
you you do really have the option
between um
in a lot of ways fighting or running or
um fighting a couple of them and then
getting back into stealth and then
failing um
yeah a lot of different ways to approach
combat
no stealth at all i actually want to say
to anyone who's planning to play this
themselves
i highly recommend not using the listen
feature
um which is mapped to r1
i believe this it'll tell you where
enemies are nearby i found it so much
more rewarding
if i just didn't touch it um figuring
out where
enemies are myself also that's another
interesting mechanic you reload
when you're not aiming by pressing r2
i keep wanting to press like square or
circle for whatever reason
you know what i've been playing that
does that but
what's it going prone that does happen a
lot
this is a bad idea
this is a bad idea you're right about
yourself
hello
good day
i mean she would have been screwed that
was a necessary shot there
where's that lookout
thank you froggy four eyes
how do people choose your usernames you
know
it's gotta be close
no
i thought i was gonna have to break this
but maybe oh yeah
that is right okay oh press x again
hello
so this is the listen mechanic like i
said i recommend people don't use it
um i found
i didn't use it and then when i
remembered it was a mechanic i was like
oh no i'm glad i haven't been using that
i feel like it makes things a lot more
atmospheric to have to actually
physically look
i think this is probably scripted she's
just gonna wait for her those sounds
should we take a look around this nice
house take a little tour we got some
time why not
i'm not gonna see myself in this with
those mirrors
nice bed posts cute room
two bathrooms right next to each other
with only one bedroom
oh did i come through bedroom i guess i
did yeah so one of them has an ensuite
the other one doesn't
i guess he's the favorite
just you buddy just you
hello they will see you if you approach
from the side
i think the human ai does a better job
oh he dropped bullets we'd love to see
it
oh i like
excuse me
hence not using listen i am an advocate
for it i don't know where he is or what
direction he went in
it's right there just not that hard but
yeah i recommend trying it
um do you people talking about leaks i
actually didn't see most of them
um but i can tell you one major leak is
completely false
i'm not going to talk about which ones i
think that i might make a video
to put up on the channel today just
because
uh i said this before but i keep seeing
the recurring comment that this game
disrespects joel and i think that is the
biggest misunderstanding from the leaks
this game is
it just doesn't uh i think that's just
completely misunderstanding
um the point entirely and i don't even
know how people really got there like
that that i feel like that's so far off
that i can't even figure out
where it came from from what leak or
whatever um
i forgot to climb the fence i remember
being stuck here last time for a bit
is it that i have to climb this it is
yeah i thought it would be too high so
that took me a while to get through last
time
you ain't seen [ __ ]
hey bud where are you going
do you think that the infected freeze
today
also every time that i see myself in the
webcam it's so shiny
look how shiny it is moisturizer ladies
and gentlemen i didn't put makeup on i
just put moisturizer on
carry skin does make you shiny
but yeah i'm sorry that my uh my face is
uh beaming beacon of light
apologize for that
look after yourselves it is more
important
moisturize in the morning and at night
different kinds of moisturizer it gets
very complicated
i only learned all of this like last
year when i went um
i spent christmas with a female friend
in palm springs and she was like
you don't even really wash your face
what the [ __ ]
i digress look at the little uh
condensation
or uh conversations definitely not the
right word
the um water the way it's frozen on the
car
the details main they about it one thing
that uh
uh comparatively just absolutely lacks
detail consistently in this game
is um so many repeats
oh you see me
yeah you see i feel like every clicker
looks the same a lot of the human
enemies look the same um
the infected i think it's maybe just
harder to notice because i say like
covered in blood but
very frequently everybody
looks the same and uh
i'm sure those assets take up a bit of
space
where's the patrol do people talk to
themselves this much in real life
i guess uh to answer
my own question um i am
sitting here in theory talking to myself
so yes i've been talking to myself for
however long the stream has been live
so yes
come on this way
okay oh it's totally
oh building okay let's keep going you
miss being with him
with jesse such a weird conversation no
we've been together for so long look
jesse's great
i love his parents
you never really talked to me about cat
yeah because
there isn't much to talk about wow
i just i got the impression that you
didn't really like her
i don't care about her one way or the
other
no i think she's a talented artist
impression being she's
the woman i like that tattoo of yours
you gave her that tattoo that's so big
of you
and i think she wasn't right for you
interesting shut up okay
um i don't like that relationship uh
because they're gay no it's not that
um i don't feel like these two
characters have any chemistry really at
all
uh i don't care about dina in the
slightest
um i think i touched on that in my q a
you're gonna point at your face aren't
you
nothing is that spectacular that doesn't
even make sense
um no i think she's really flat she's
sure she makes a lot of jokes but
ellie's reaction is usually just
yeah um yeah that was my most immediate
like why are you making me spend time
with this chick because i just don't
i don't like nina and i don't care about
dina
um and i don't feel like i feel like
they like each other
which is a bummer what do you think of
this view huh
it's pretty nice but you're also not
with a constantly
yeah this route has its perks
where do we sign in
come on i do like this wall building
there first
they're very good at it anyway just like
why do we sign in instead of
someone explaining so we go on routes
and we start in it's it's a lot more um
i don't know just they're good at the
the show not tell kind of writing i
think
uh shashank i am reading chat but i'm
trying not to do it too much
um because i am really just trying to
show people the game
and i'm gonna leave this video up so
people can see the first few hours of
the game so i'm trying to not make it
too
heavy jesse i'm sorry about that i will
i will interact with you guys just not
right doing it constantly because i'm
playing a video game man he was funny
oh yeah
i love that ellie doesn't help yeah you
got it plus
he taught me about rewiring electronics
and stuff
rewiring electronics and stuff dina
ladies and gentlemen didn't make it to
73.
all right don't i just don't care about
her
i keep thinking that she probably has a
good ass but you can never see it
because she's always wearing a coat
thank you caleb most of us australia's
just mad max
man why don't we get a scorching desert
i can't have this nice snowman
hmm coffee huh
this place is like sort of well kept
together all things considered this is
like a
comfortable couch i didn't see that
can i get high right now hey i'm gonna
guess this bong was your jeans
yeah it's mine he gave it to me
oh we've got us
sorry i can't help it like ah
my bad sometimes you know you just shut
a door with your arm and then you have
to reopen it we've all been there
uh generally though this game does
control well
it is really smooth it's as smooth as
they made it look um
i mean i assume you guys can tell that
yeah it feels so much better to play
than the first one
tommy and joel found two clickers by the
gas station and cleared them otherwise
clear
on 12 28 oh i guess they don't
it's not a frequent schedule it's kind
of all over the place
yes sign thing damn you write fast
come here you often get these uh dial-up
prompts
um or you can choose to interact with
someone
i recommend doing it
there's the town with the big tower
thing
yep big tower thing ellie come on now
you know better
ah there's a ski lodge that's the one on
tommy and joel's road
mm-hmm and also here's the one
dina's crew is staying in i believe
if you look at the front of that i
wonder why they didn't choose to post up
here
like look at all the space i guess it's
like harder to manage that many
buildings infected in there
all right let's get back to the horses
indeed
question were you wearing those same
clothes yesterday
they're clean another thing i like about
the writing judgment
very simple but that's an example of
when she woke up
it's patrol you know and she's you see
that ellie's asleep in jeans you still
look nice um your brain goes why the
hell has she done that what's she
wearing jeans for in our sleep
um look loot
uh game answers all those questions
it um it does a good job of that it's
like well incineration was she passed
out drunk
and then you know people also ask her
the same questions that you would ask
um that happened a few times in ways
that i was like
anything i kind of wonder about they
generally tend to answer but
you know just a little bit after you
wonder alrighty let's go
horses don't give up what about
we're doing it i think we should go out
like eugene
from a stroke no
from old age like living a long life
you no way come on you're way too
reckless
look who's talking
you'll probably die from hypothermia
from wearing canvas sneakers in the snow
i am wearing clothes today i finally got
called out for a
converse types converse types
all right
patrolling the town should we check
these houses out
it seems quiet but we can if you want i
bet they still got supplies
do we want to do that sure
let me take a load of houses
i definitely didn't do this the first
time i played through so
why not it sometimes does surprise me
how aggressively it looks like these
places have been ransacked
but people really have left stuff around
just another evacuated neighborhood
but we yeah
catch them on the outer perimeter
why they don't come out this fall what
are you doing tonight it's all snowed in
uh i was
i think i can get it anyways
these trailers are neat nice little
portable home
do you think people really traveled a
lot in these things
oh wouldn't you i mean if i had lived
pre-outbreak
yeah i wanted to see the whole training
upgrades yet or travel to another
country i don't have enough so maybe one
day
keep dreaming
jesse talks a lot about going to canada
he said there's these like
giant waterfalls out there he wanted to
see really
he's such a hardcore jackson guy
everybody's got their dream
the idea that people wouldn't know what
niagara falls are is is pretty funny
like yeah conversations about not
getting to go to other parts of the
world i guess like they just have to
think of like
what are the conversations that you
would have with another young person in
the apocalypse
what movie are you guys gonna watch
shimmer uh
curtis and viper ii that's the one
that's been on that real radar for a
while
oh wow you live in niagara falls
congrats joey i bet it's beautiful i've
never been
hmm
[ __ ] the temperature dropped
i gotta jump this i think
[ __ ]
more than one do they do that where the
hell are they
happens in the first game
equip long gun i love a good long
gun
what i don't believe it's a rifle
[ __ ] i hear some inside
yeah i think that's just effective how
the [ __ ] did they get in there
time to die
that's how ellie kills people ladies and
gentlemen
she always and i'm i don't know if
there's a functional purpose for this
but when she stabs them in the throat as
she does that's why
she pushes the knife out which means
blood goes everywhere i don't know if
there's like
a reason that she does that but it seems
so aggressive i don't know um
it's like easy to take a knife out that
way i don't know but it does mean it's
it's
it's bloody in here
hey you got any free stuff obama
devastating
that is true lactose usually can be
opened from the other side usually you
can break through a window or whatever
i do oh hey buddy
well i didn't mean to do that but
are you good yeah i don't do that as
much as i should
nice throw by the way you've forgotten
that that was a thing
that i should do she's still
i honestly just avoid them and then
shoot them if they notice me
yeah that's a good question
what's the most infected you've ever
taken down on patrol it's
gotta be the one i had with joel a year
or so ago
it was like i don't know a dozen
you cleared about 20 once
it was a great
so this is pretty cool if she does it
she is doing it yeah the uh
friendly ai see again
uh the friendly ai actually will uh help
you
which is great for everyone involved
they don't consistently do it and it's
actually kind of hard to get a read on
when they will and when they want
um but they can be useful
there's a runner in that store where is
it
there's two of them okay again
campaigning but don't use listen
all right we're just gonna i'm just
gonna i hope he doesn't turn around and
i'm gonna go for this guy
emo king over in the corner dina i hope
you take care of the other one
but i don't have that much faith in you
because i think you suck
except that i think you probably have a
good ass
but i can't get a solid read on it did
she not do it useless
uh because she's always wearing a jacket
all right yeah come for me then fam
you want to play let's [ __ ] play
get out of here
she's flicking the blood off my knife oh
david did say that's his unlikely
explanation
he might be right it's uh
i see how bloody it is
at all hot seat i caught see looks fine
actually
it doesn't look very bloody looks like
it surprisingly unsweetened
the ones in the supermarket let's keep
circling the building
there's gotta be a way in do you think
that in this universe there is a point
where they run
out of infected like there just aren't
any more to kill you
that's the thing that happens
i guess every time there are spores or
oh no i think i have to lift dino don't
i
this is another part where i feel like i
got lost maybe i can climb myself i feel
like this is what i have to do
but i'm not positive if i could be
completely wrong
yeah that's what i thought up you go
idiot don't make me wait for you
ellie help me up there i want to look
around
cool go for it all right go ahead
let's watch i'd love to see it love to
see it
infected shouldn't be able to survive
winter in the north right there's a hole
in the roof over there
the pot with abby earlier i guess you do
see a bunch of them frozen and i didn't
um
look to see if they'd been shot or if
they just kind of died in the snow
so i don't actually know thanks look
see all right you might be right maybe
some of them do freeze some of them
don't i'm not sure
okay
under here how are the frame rates
i don't know i haven't done a test
okay
ellie are you clean yeah
yeah just banged up everybody please
don't worry about ellie getting bit
affected i really don't have to shoot
you in the face
not super concerned but thank you deal
cool
okay
actually yeah nice ma'am i'm sorry to
god for what i did
i wasn't going to hurt you i didn't want
anything from your store except for the
drugs your husband came at me what
choice did i have
my little sister stopped feeling her
feet i needed the insulin everyone is
hoarding the stuff what choice did i
have i hope he survives i'm sorry
i almost feel like this note
is a testament to this entire universe
a lot of people doing a lot of [ __ ] up
stuff but
generally out of desperation uh
rather than hate forever
not sure
i think i would still kill last time too
but i think it said i have to jump up
here
okay
here we go
oh you won't watch but you need to know
is the game worth playing i definitely
think this game is worth playing yes
embargo has been lifted elijah yes
what's my opinion of the story
i will make tons more videos about that
um trying not to talk about um
me too i mean i already spoke about that
i think in the last video should we
check recipe but i will have a lot more
content about that i'm trying not to get
too far ahead of myself in this
uh
oh do we just move this is that what
we're supposed to do
seems like it'd be really easy to do
that
frankly this is where i'm supposed to be
right have i done something wrong
is it just that i have to keep waiting
for [ __ ] dina to do things
like honestly
oh demographic 25 to 38 do you think
this is the demographic for this game
25-38 i feel like
maybe that's right who knows
brand refresh differentiate ourselves
from our competition
yeah core values
partner with local farms i wonder what
uh what kind of business y'all are
though
gross profits always buy under arrow
oh my god that asset is reused so much
that practice hard work focus is
everywhere in this game is
just everywhere
um okay seriously i really would have
thought that i'm supposed to go through
here
oh
oh hello liquid hey
that's what i was waiting to do a couple
of fine alcohol
you need to make a med cake that makes
sense that's yourself nonsense
is this streaming safe uh yeah you'll be
fine to stream it
i guess it's just like on mixer you
would have to have the correct um
not that i'm assuming you're streaming
on mixer but yes you're allowed to
stream the game
it is definitely very violent i would
just say that you would have to disclose
that if you're trying to get ads or
whatever
there you go that's what we were
supposed to do and then dina moves the
card across because ellie can't
again i don't know masks on
got it had a lot of people ask about um
why ellie was pictured wearing a mosque
in some of the gameplay i posted earlier
i don't want to have to shoot you in the
face
oh that's so sweet um if you're just
joining us
nobody really knows she's immune
all these spores maybe she's been here
first things up
keep your eyes peeled or infected yep
is this part of the supermarket i don't
know
i don't know i think we're above it
let's get to the ground oh yes pots pots
pots give me pots
i think that's it i think that's it okay
uh where am i supposed to go from here
aha
trusty x-door crack oh you guys are you
ready for the single best puzzle in the
game
you should be
this tops all of the puzzles in this
game
wow safe i don't know how to open it how
am i going to do that
oh combination too big
couldn't possibly guess a note
yo kristen left the real [ __ ] in the
safe for you combo is the date my good
boy got employee of the month don't
[ __ ] sell those or give them away
that's your back all right feel better
that's for you back sorry
pictured good boy who at some point
did get employee of the month
look at him oh i bet he was great july
2013.
i'm just gonna make the code
zero seven
twenty
a thirteen
oh [ __ ] we like a good boy
we do see neil druckmann doesn't hate
dogs
it's just really that the dogs hate you
if anything
there are some points in this game where
you kill a dog and the owner cries out
the dog's name
and there was one part that really got
me because the dog name was bear
and the owner was like bear and i used
to call my labrador bear
and it got me it got me back
it's very sad but it's supposed to be
you aren't supposed to feel like you're
doing everything good all the time
for sure that's uh
if i were to say the theme of this game
i would say it's about
consequence morality
all right cool another creepy
crack
oh [ __ ] did i just shut
i don't know if you guys saw me tweet
this
but i find click is in this game
so disgusting that it makes me feel like
i'm gonna vomit not every time
but they have just this effect on me
when i actually really look at the
details combined to
combine with the way they sound where i
just like
um shamblers which are one of the new
enemy types of the same i just find them
so [ __ ] gross to look at which is
a massive credit to the design team
look at the skid it's just so
ah so gross
on the flip side a lot of people have
asked me if the game's scary
i'm a coward when it comes to horror
games i get scared
despite loving them
i don't find any other stuff scary you
guys scared
i don't know why these blind
[ __ ] make my skin crawl
let's make sure they're racist you're
already saying based on this stream that
you don't think the story is good
what speaking my language
um yeah no you guys aren't scared either
it's uh i don't know why it just doesn't
i could be looting more but
ah this yeah maybe i'll keep playing i
don't know
i don't know i don't feel the need to
you know somebody
will help come in
there are definitely parts of it that
are atmospheric and spooky but i just
don't frequently find it scary
oh i let go too early that was on me
that was my bad
i did that that wasn't on dina i don't
like you
but it wasn't your fault
who is this guy happy dude
i'll take a present that's his face
hey thank you johnny hi ellie
you think a listen mode takes away the
scary atmosphere uh like i said i'm not
using it
something about someone standing and
holding a molotov is very
creepy looking doesn't she still have
the infection on her arm though
you'll see are there a lot of jump
scares there are jump scares john but
not
a ton
careful with that i'm a pro no let me
just let that get absorbed by my
backpack real quick don't worry about it
don't worry about it
i also never really use molotovs
everything is stealth
i got some numbers here go for the run
as fast
stab you in the neck
push it forward when i take it out
for some reason oh hey bud hey bud hey
bud
you wouldn't like happen to be thinking
about turning around would you because i
don't think that's a good idea
that clicker over there i like to think
is jamming out that's how you dance to
dubstep
is the way that clickers move when
they're in a in the staying in a spot
how else do you dance to dubstep i don't
know
um all right again no listen mode
strongly throat you can see there's
clicker there there's a runner there
i think there might be it's the runner
i'm worried about and he sees me
two clickers and just one runner
i gotta take him out without him seeing
me so that they don't see me
shouldn't be too hard
daniel did
the only game that scared you was dead
space
i get really scared of games i love
horror games
and hare in general love horror movies
but games really scare me
it's always really hard um back when i
reviewed video games
uh to review a horror game because you
can get so scared that you don't want to
play but you have to get through it for
review purposes so i just started
sprinting everywhere
in virtually every horror game i just
look how thick she is girl look at those
hips
but again all the clickers have the same
[ __ ] character model it's the same
old lady
with her fat ass
did you think i was blind dina
or did ellie say that which one of you
idiots thought that i didn't see that
clicker oh a nickel
we take them where we can get them folks
um
i looked at it too long and then my
mouth started feeling sick again
but uh you know i
i haven't seen a titty in years
it's probably not true i feel like
ellie's probably seen a titty and like
more recently than that
nice that her nipple didn't decay and
everything else did
all right love you are wearing different
clothing but it is the exact same hair
you're just well no you're wearing
clothing i'm always amazing
ass doesn't look as fatty though i think
that was a male clipper
oh look at his face oh god it's so gross
okay
i feel like i should just tweet it
really everyone play this without using
the listen mechanic i highly recommend
i think everybody's dead and he's still
moving
uh nope
cool you know what
i'm impressed with us yeah
man the guys are not going to believe
our numbers
hmm forgot about it let's go to the next
lookout
i guess they would though in this i mean
no absolutely people would who am i
kidding
in this kind of universe people would
spend virtually all of their time
bragging about
how many infected they killed because
literally what else do they have to brag
about
that's it
everything is scripted af i agree with
that real quick
uh yes okay naughty dogs make very
scripted
cinematic games that is absolutely
okay
um environments do get way bigger and
you do have a lot of ways to
approach combat if you want to cable
here but i mean yeah it's scripted
here we go
get your cable here i should hold this
get over here [ __ ] yeah
all right ellie okay it wasn't you threw
some rope okay you don't need to be you
know
cheerleading yourself here we go all the
time
not that hard not that hard it's part
one story better than part two they're
very very different
i prefer the story of part one
but they are really different stories
they also just directly correlate like i
really do think that this game is
i'm trying not to get too far ahead of
myself but i keep feel like i keep doing
it
i feel like this game is very much about
never mind i'm not gonna say it i'm not
gonna say it
i'm just gonna stop seriously ellie that
had to hurt
at least a little bit for you to like
have a like look out
come on now
following you okay
let's go we're ready
dean i said i was following you so if
you could speed up me let me type
okay how far away are we a few minutes
down
okay
get your hood up
i was in a blizzard once in alaska
it sucked it's getting worse
oh thank you the machine
doesn't seem to be letting me run right
now
yeah okay yeah she really [ __ ] up
this is why we hate dana this way she's
still
going i don't dislike her that much too
before i am
playing it up for uh entertainment
purposes but
yeah she's my least favorite character
i think
i'll get the door
have a good one i run over here i
appreciate that what do i dislike about
it i just think she's very flat
never came inside she's a really flat
character
all right uh let's make sure it's clear
yeah just
it's again it's not actually that i
dislike it it's just that i don't like
her uh i just don't find her
particularly interesting i don't feel
like she has much to offer
she just makes lame jokes really
okay [ __ ]
good thing i could do this
no [ __ ] what's going on here
look how much detail there is man video
games ten years ago
like not that you should compare games
now like two games ten years ago
this would have been empty yeah nobody
else would tinker with this [ __ ]
so much stuff why would he hide it from
me
was right definitely eugene's place
eugene
he was a firefly he served with tommy
why can't i put it away thank
no i like ellie i definitely like ellie
they got this no it's dino though
[ __ ] don't love like what
i like elliot a checkpoint a denver qz
kill three soldiers and two civilians
jesus he also told me that
he and tommy tweeted some big fedra
general
i don't know i don't buy tommy doing
that
he could do worse what do you mean
he and joel did a lot to survive after
the outbreak
oh because he lived here i was like why
is that here
yeah definitely this is a pretty sick
place to live dude
i'd live in a library for sure
oh workbench i think
oh my god it's tommy and eugene
they look like babies here
i've seen you when you was a baby
lights eugene i'm begging you to come
home there's gotta be
fireflies this one's 200. fireflies want
to save the world i say let them
let them go after the military the
politicians let them develop a vaccine
to save mankind
maybe one day we'll live to see the
fruits of their fantasies until then i
have to put our daughter first the
fireflies will be fine without you your
daughter won't she keeps asking me when
you're coming home i can't lie to her
anymore
i miss you but i don't know how much
more of this i can take come on please
we love you claire
they do just i think i've already said
it such a good job
of giving you an idea of who the human
was who lived in a space
and why and you know what kind of person
they were
um it's a thing that i feel like
is worth playing slowly on the generator
uh because there is just so much
beautiful world building
if you want to play it [ __ ]
nope again let it bounce there you go
that's that is a mini game that i feel
like they use like over and over and
over again
oh wow impressive work bench eugene
i bet you could mod your gun with this
gear wow
thanks i sure can a lot of people have
these workbenches apparently
uh let's do this
what do we want
fire right i can only get one
sums up finally what time is it
seven um
weapon spray recoil
i'm gonna go with more rounds
i don't feel like the guns are terribly
difficult to handle i could always use
more ammo
it's pretty
okay
want to go from here oh stop building
stop it
here we go dean has found whatever it is
that we need to find
ellie look at the floor there's more
stuff down there
you see way down
not here multiple floors you say
what kind of building has that
yeah you can physically see the upgrades
um boo rep
you can is a dlc for this um
well gee uh i don't know yet i don't
i imagine they'll probably make a
standalone dlc type thing but um
getting a bit ahead of yourself there i
think cool
secret passageway come on
what's he got down here very cool well
it's obviously a sex den
that's why he didn't tell you about it i
hope it's a sex death
for his sake he was so lonely man
wow why do you have to roast him like
that
he thought you'd text up or whatever it
wasn't you said oh my god it's weed
that's a lot of dead weed this explains
a lot
why are you gonna grow this much unless
you can use it for currency
maybe he was seems like an excessive
amount unless he found some other pups
for it
maria would lose her [ __ ] if she saw
this place
but what do i need to get this together
i
that's ridiculous it's absolutely right
dina
it's a gas mask bong
god he was so smart
is that smart i honestly don't know
i rolled some oh
there we go you think it's still good
does weed go bad i'm just gonna ask that
all right dina sometimes we are on the
same page does weed go bad
um someone said something about what i
play a heads up
do you have another place to potential
spoilers not sure uh
i don't think i can turn off
oh did my twitch stream go now looks
like you guys still have it okay
yeah have i played this part already i
have
finished the game oh [ __ ] it
you could have just lost her is wrong
with you
i got it open didn't i tina
i mean we're gonna be stuck here a while
right
oh cause that snowed in totally trapped
this would probably hit for me if again
i cared about them as characters or if
they had some kind of build up i don't
know
maybe if you watch their relationship
develop maybe that's why
i'm not into it okay because you jump
into this game at a point where
ellie and dina already knew each other
one being i guess i'm also treating them
like all of them kelly's only 19. she
acts like a 19
life altar maybe i'm not quite giving it
credit for that
how would you like i wouldn't ask
someone
yes from last night
why are we still talking about this
you said it was a mistake
did i say that
there's any more of this gay stuff about
i think this is the uh kiss
the gayest part of this game pretty much
is actually this moment
right now for the record i don't know
i give it a six a six
oh that's pretty rude wow like a solid
six
okay there are a lot of people around
yeah but six
oh what i mean now i really want to know
how you'd rate it
i don't think you do i don't care
you're infuriating
have you met you
you made me want to go back outside into
that blizzard
no one is stopping you
what if you lit the whole place on fire
ellie
she'll raise you terribly
you know sometimes she's gonna get high
and make out with someone
during an apocalyptic blizzard
i mean to be fair i would do it i just
don't care about their relationship
all right love okay posh juxtaposition
from that make out sesh
is this i think
this oh my god there are too many of
them
oh no that seems fine
yeah you got those uncharted butt slides
back
there are a few chase sequences like
this
not today [ __ ]
um i think we are getting extra close to
extra spoilery territory
game design make me think oh okay okay
up this way
damn it no no no
no i
no i'm aware
it got out of hand
i also do feel like every part of this
game where you mash
uh square can [ __ ] off i need to turn
it
thank you i appreciate it
you okay yeah
where the hell they all come from how
many games are
those that's where more have been in
together i reckon we go out the back
we can make a break for the lodge
come on i gotta warn everyone just if i
come back with a cleanup crew
we got to live through these trucks god
damn it
fishes are everywhere
did i just leave you guys sorry
no you got it though
i like the uh the way the camera moves
up
she looks so mad
something about this particular
feels like a theme park right push it up
under the car
i think because of the urgency of what
you're doing and having two
characters
when they're on the ground
up
don't you punch in love well that's
get this
damn i should've shut her again
should've shown her again
stupid
take a punch
oh that one dude
yeah the auto him is pretty aggressive
but it also doesn't um
to the head so you do have to do that
i'm sure this game has a really good
accessibility settings
so i'm sure there's a way to come on go
um make it all under the head probably
but
yeah it locks on but uh they will take
multiple
actually yeah
this stuff is super cinematic
hey i'm tommy she sounds so much like
ellie
we cannot stay here horses ain't making
it all that my friends
my friends are at a mansion just north
of here it's fenced in we have the whole
perimeter secured
correctly oh god
i'll get the door you ride with me
sometimes human bodily functions
difficult
again that is a like high intensity
section of this game
this is um yeah it's intense
what about this one damn it
but still don't find it scary i don't
know why really weird
oh and oh i've tried to get it shave
your armpits
and it shot right out from underneath me
wait how did you get the scar yes
shaving wouldn't really be priority only
[ __ ]
okay um
this is important if you would like to
know a chemical burn if not i hope you
have already left
i doubt myself
why
uh
to cover a bite mark
right here
i got jumped by and infected when i was
14.
and turns out i'm
immune so it healed before she delivered
that one
[ __ ] up teeth marks and cis and ow
[ __ ] you what hey
i told you a real [ __ ] story i did
tell you a real [ __ ] story oh you
want a bite mark
do you hear that jesse
just stay there okay i feel really weird
about seeing ellie half naked
i feel like i'm a dad you know what
brown what are you doing
kidding me
you're supposed to be on patrol there's
a blizzard and i'm pretty sure that is
the end of any
why are you here affection you see in
this entire get that that's pretty much
it do matters
well then why aren't you at the [ __ ]
lookout because tommy and joel didn't
show up
what do you mean
way later maybe they just went back to
town
without being replaced no way another
people
how much of their region have you
covered uh
then we split up go at it from different
sides
and we can cover the whole thing in a
few hours i don't like you riding solo
we don't know what's out there
exactly what if they need help
okay i'll head west dena can take south
and you come from the east but be smart
about it yeah
oh
i keep thinking that the guy with a
little ponytail is nail dropping
let's get inside
the chat has not already uh warned you
i hope not because that's full of
spoilers you should leave
us if you don't want the spoilers
we're good thanks yeah can i talk to you
for a minute
you want to get those saddles off no no
it's all right we'll just
ride out the storm
how long y'all been here since yesterday
yesterday yep what are y'all doing out
this way
i'm just passing through you two live
nearby
we do a few hours down the hill you all
should come back with us restock before
you head out
that's so nice appreciate it i'm mel by
the way
tommy she is pregnant
joe
i like like you heard westerson they are
literally
here because they have my dude
all clear he's out put him against the
wall
zombie it's super messed up the way is
look at him i feel like it like totally
does look like him
joel miller
who are you guess
i love him so much
why don't you say whatever speech you
got rehearsed
get this over with
they were so nice to her i guess that's
like echoes through the whole game
though
tourniquet is like doesn't matter do it
there are ways in which she is nice that
uh other people take advantage of too
you [ __ ] move
i just can't remember what i feel like
on your name
just look at it oh god
i did do that to a dog's face in an
earlier playthrough i actually shot a
dog in the face with a shotgun
it wasn't pretty
stupid old man
you don't get to rush this
i feel like this might all be
how do i get down there
no that sounds like i have to do it
this is the right way to go
joel tommy
i guess from ellie's perception right
now
they with with all the infected by the
gate
she would just think that they've been
chased by um
zombies are one of them
joel tommy
all right love not that hard
where's that coming from i hate to see
it
not papa bear though
look at it just [ __ ]
beautiful place to be tortured you know
if ever i've seen one
i actually don't remember exactly where
it is though i thought the door was over
that way but
downstairs makes sense it's where i
would torture someone
oh sweet baby
okay
sorry it's not appropriate for me to be
laughing at nail dropping i'm good
who is that why aren't you posted up
outside we didn't think anyone was going
to show up the hell did you expect
we got to get out of here before the
whole town's on top of us
you're done the [ __ ] is wrong with that
one right
what the [ __ ] look at your elbows
halfway down your arm
that's weird am i the only one seeing
that
jewel get up you'll [ __ ] get up
please stop please don't
shoot joe please get up
he's very [ __ ] up the chat to watch
i feel like he just wouldn't have wanted
it either you wouldn't have wanted her
to see it
and i hate that like it sucks that he
knew
so this is obviously them deliberating
on what to do with her
got a kick in the face that'll do it to
you
that'll do it to you
trash why is it trash ellie it's just so
silly
the haters so silly you don't even know
why they did it
i completely understand why they did it
but also this is not the last you see of
joel in this game i think joel is like
almost the main character honestly he's
the most important piece of this entire
game
consistently everything is about him
even if you don't play as him
which you do see them plenty more
it's not like they just do that and then
[ __ ] off you know definitely context you
folks don't
don't have why kill him like that
there's a reason
good one guys just want to hate it
i don't know if you know why they did it
no i don't think it's bad
there are things i don't like about this
game but i don't think that choice
is bad even in the slightest
hi hey
hey
could i sit down please yeah
she's so unscathed for how [ __ ] up
she's been in the last 24 hours you
should be covered in bruises woman come
on now
covered in them you had a bad time
maria wants to make sure you're eating
she can't stop us
to have the guys that we would need
to do this smart
no i definitely don't agree
it makes perfect sense it really does
just get to get away with that but i'll
be able to talk about that
later yeah but that's what's happening
it's supposed to make you mad you know
because
you are supposed to fully be as
motivated as early
that's a valid point if it were you
totally joel would be halfway to seattle
already
that wouldn't he absolutely [ __ ]
would be well we don't even know for
certain
that they're from seattle washington
liberation front that's what you said
was on those patches
what if they stole those jackets that's
that's a wlf move what are you doing
honestly having patches on you that
identify exactly where you're from is
probably a bad [ __ ] idea
i'm leaving tomorrow
and if you want to come with me great
why that just don't put the patches on
then people can't identify you it's so
dumb
you have no idea what you're walking
into
you don't know how large that group is
how armed i don't
care
you can't talk me out of this
yeah i wouldn't carry them i would do it
especially the way they did it yeah
you'd be like no [ __ ] that [ __ ]
i will die to kill as many of you
[ __ ] as possible
give me a day to talk to maria
okay there's got to be some folks you
can spare
and if she won't budge
well i'll figure something out
one day
please
fine your eyes look really good for sure
can you miss joel so much there's a lot
more joel in this game like i said tons
and tons of joel
you see him a bunch more um doesn't end
here
but yeah it's definitely supposed to
just make you really [ __ ] mad
you know he became an old man he stops
he's not journeying anymore he's retired
you got soft when you
[ __ ] over tons and tons of people they
don't care about that context
i had to kill them too well
lesbian i wouldn't kill anyone but maybe
in the apocalypse yeah he's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i have conflict of interest because i'm
troy's friend no one cares about how
he's dead
if you say so fam i just want you guys
to to play it or to not try to hate it
because that's what's happening right
i uh
um yeah definitely i'm friends with troy
though
but that has no bearing on how i feel
about
writing i want to stop at his house
before we leave
people getting upset by brutal and
upsetting choice in a brutal and
upsetting game and then try to cover for
their insecurity with its bad writing
when they haven't played the actual game
you are supposed to get upset jason that
is the point you are
100 supposed to be angry but
that's what fuels the everything that
you do after this point is you're
supposed to be really [ __ ] mad
um we hate it because we're such big
fans of the first game this game makes
no sense i don't agree with that at all
he uh he [ __ ] up and he got
consequences for [ __ ] up
and
that that's that's what happens that's
what happens
um and you as as people who are really
attached to them which i totally am too
and i do really love
everything to do with joel on this game
i love the way that they show him you
know there
he like i said their flashbacks we see a
lot more of them
he has something else out on the way
he's supposed to pull on your
heartstrings for sure
apocalypse is going to [ __ ]
apocalypse though
a lot harder then it's going to be
harder
you can still change your mind you know
i know again i think she probably has a
good ass but it's always covered and
it's devastating
if i can see a click of teddy i could
see dana butt maybe i should have looked
when she was off naked
i didn't think so i'm just bad at uh
sexualizing my characters i guess i
should have tried harder
not thirsty enough you know room for
improvement
you need to get your backpack i hit it
by the east gates
i figured we'd want to slip out that way
would i recommend this game
yeah official this is a very well making
uh my score out of ten like look i'm not
giving it one
but i keep saying like maybe a seven or
eight is probably what i would give it
but like that's very vague and i don't
like
having to score things people just keep
asking me is that a rabbit
it's gonna be joel's house
i don't know why ellie would choose to
live in like that weird shitty studio
when joel has an
entire goddamn house but
we are hey
what do you need oh i can go get it
i want to do it okay
i'm okay come on
i'll hang out down here i um did
experience the first time but we'll do
it again anyway
it's charles house
what are you living like i like this old
bad joel is just
the side of him you don't really see
much of he's got a bunch of books and
dino i guess
that was a good day sure was
pretty good drawing i don't know why i'm
saying that like i'm surprised that
ellie's a good artist even though she
has a journal full of good art
paints in her own house i think this is
really pretty
he got beans seeds
potatoes tomatoes am i playing this in
new game
plus or just a fresh game i literally
just hit new game normal i did it real
real quickly uh why didn't
dina or tommy help ellie was that the
question
i i don't both tommy and ellie were
pinned down
um obviously they
let them go because they were like
didn't feel the need to
kill more people they had sympathy for
them
which was probably a bad [ __ ] idea
i don't know why i like seeing
characters in video game mirrors so much
what she got out of bro
also where did you get this art from i
assume art decay's pretty cool oh no it
does have glass on it maybe
maybe not no it doesn't you can see the
paint lines
damn [ __ ] dude all out he has a lot
of art though
who painted it who painted it i don't
know i don't know
how long am i going to play i'll do
maybe like another
hour maybe i don't know we'll see i mean
you know i only got like three hours
sleep
um it's been a very busy week
woke up early to be able to do this so
yeah i'm not sure we'll see
so what was the jaw reveal trailer for
if they intended on killing them off why
did they do it i don't remember the jolt
reveal trailer i don't even know what
you're talking about
um but there is a lot
of uh joel in this game like i keep
saying how do they know simply based on
the first name that he was the joel they
were looking for
they knew he was in that area so they
specifically went to that location
to find joel and then when they find out
it's joel and tommy who both
names they know they go oh [ __ ] um it is
like totally worth noting though that
that stuff that you don't think about is
they don't know what he looks like
because they wouldn't know what he looks
like all they know is what they've heard
this dude did
um which yeah you'd think he [ __ ]
sucked
um maybe joel painted them it is
definitely as you can tell sorry
in regards to the painting i assume that
is you can tell he
he he'd be crafty in his old age but i
don't think he has any paints up here
like that's super cool i love this this
old mandrel and these little hobbies
these bicky guitars
oh nice boy
i think that's something very um smart
about
having something so [ __ ] violent and
awful happen and then letting you walk
through
his house and see what he was up to and
what he was like
in his slightly older age he's not that
old
uh it makes sense from abby's
perspective but it sucks from rounds and
you'll sell in the game to us
um you're supposed to be upset about
that though again there are things in
this game that i don't like
like i don't i don't think it's a 10 out
of 10. i have finished it mikey yeah
um but you're not supposed to like it
because that is your driving force
for everything that happens after this
point right you're supposed to be really
[ __ ] mad
about what happened to joel um you're
supposed to love him
they're banking on the fact that
everyone likes him so that you have
complete relation to the absolute rage
airlie feels to go on to do everything
she does after this point
um i think that all makes perfect sense
that they kill someone you love that she
loves
you want to [ __ ] people up you know i
totally understand
they they channeled out super well
um and then the rest of it is a matter
of finding out how and also how their
relationship developed and who he became
and all of that stuff again i think this
this game
or the one like internet criticism i've
seen that i think is the most wrong is
that the game disrespects joel this game
is really about joel is so much about
what he does and who he became
and the sweet things he did
yeah it's it's i almost feel like more
of a story about joel than it is about
anyone else
it's just that you play it from other
people's perspectives but it is it's
like
it feels like a tribute to him doing it
i love that she [ __ ] takes this
watching this gun
she keeps his gun i love that
he's also got his space books these
little reading glosses
everything okay you just said i met him
was reading space books
something just makes me so sad about
thinking about joel
who's [ __ ] chilling in here as an old
man
it's just so nice he's got his records
maybe he's up there and he'd listen to
his music
man
it's definitely a strong attachment we
all have to that video game character
i tell you that i feel the same way
about ellie
and then i have a really strong
attachment to her too but in a very
different way
maybe that's why i don't like dina
you're like you didn't earn this who are
you
you [ __ ] off mostly because she's
uninteresting
but um yeah i'll let you guys listen to
this
maria i'm headed to seattle
i wish i could let it go but i can't
i have to bring these people to justice
ellie's gonna try to come after me but
stop her
take her guns lock up the horses maybe
lock her up
buy me some time so i can end this do
they explain why they didn't kill tommy
and ellie back then yeah they do explain
tommy yeah
he's gonna get himself killed he should
have taken me with him
you should have given us a group to go
after those [ __ ] i wish i
could it couldn't have been a different
job in the exact right place and then
you tell me
[ __ ] i prefer that you say but i know
you better
you going with her yeah
so you're just gonna sneak out of here
yeah one foot yeah
i like this
i told the stable to let you out with
your horse
grab some ammo too
thank you maria
just die do me a favor and
bring my dumb ass husband home in one
piece please
of course so tommy already
left all right he died to make ellie try
to stay
you're losing light naturally it didn't
walk
because of course you wouldn't just stay
put after seeing that happen
[ __ ] no i mean no i was gonna say did
they expect her too but clearly she
didn't she's being like you're gonna
leave anyway what am i gonna do
and i guess we don't know at this point
how much people in the town love joel
but you'd think
more people would go but
yeah he was right i guess we don't know
how big the wlf is how many of them
there
are a lot of risks involved
upset that nice relatively peaceful
jackson
um life they have going
this hunter was on top of him drowning
him and
joel couldn't get to his gun geez
were you scared well i didn't even think
i just just ran in there grabbed his gun
and
[ __ ] how old were you 14.
no fully conscious non-fungal person
10 wow what happened
guy was coming at my mom i stabbed him
killing joel wasn't the problem is the
way they did it and got me beat
yeah i'm a real badass yeah i think
so how lost they're [ __ ] mad
this is a loading screen you're sort of
not wrong yes they do just hide the
loading screens in this game very well
what about those crazy cannibals you
said you and joel ran into
they came after you guys once maybe
these wlfs are connected squirrels that
are running up the trees now
doesn't seem like the same group maybe
those black market smugglers back in
boston
do you not joel crossed a lot of people
this is what australian rainforest looks
like actually
okay at least until we find out more
information
rabbits
don't let me trample you fam get out of
the way
i uh it's one thing that i spoke about
in that video that i made that i really
like
is that they make it clear where you
have to go you know that path is obvious
that's where i need to go
i could veer over there if they want but
they do a good job of hiding the
invisible walls in the game or the edges
of levels
like i can't see a box you know
um i think that's just the thing that is
really consistent
is the environment's just really well
flushed out
and big really big if we're about to get
into seattle i guess it takes a little
while to actually get into seattle
don't know how much longer i'm going to
stream for we'll see um fine right now
cars yeah we're getting close
start keeping an eye on the seattle area
is big but actually that one i kind of
think is big in a needless way
now that i think back to it i don't know
that it needed to be that big it almost
feels a little bit like
look how big this environment we made is
i don't know that they needed it to be
that big
i don't know that it it is beneficial
for players to be that large
but here we go undecided i guess i was
wrong
turns out you can do that
shut up dina nobody likes you am i at
all excited for koso tsushima i am for
sure
can you try to walk out to the walls if
you do you just get stuck on trees
because obviously there are a lot of
trees
so it doesn't work that way
all right nothing i need to stop at this
yeah but um why not
oh yeah alcohol love to see it let's get
lit
good so this is actually pretty cool and
one of
the only times you see this in this game
this map of seattle
is one that you actually use um and
you'll mark where you are and where
you've been
you guys will see but i like the
the map for sure shout out to miasmata
oh ladies and gentlemen i have these
like few games that i recommend
as like must plays for understandings of
certain mechanics in video games
they're not necessarily good but mia
smarter something
have i had a chance to try the
accessibility settings yet i can show
them to you real quick
if we go to options accessibility
um i've not been using any of them
if i were to use one what would it be
i would really like to get rid of the
tap x sorry tap square
i don't know if you guys know i have
tendonitis um in both of my wrists from
[ __ ] video games and not from having
sex with video games from playing video
games
and uh so yeah this is all basic
basically like stuff that would make the
game super easy
um
enhanced dodge could actually make the
game feel a little bit better dodge
doesn't always feel great invisible
well-prone blah blah
navigation and traversal would that be
it maybe navigation assistance
no no
no i don't know where it is i do i'll do
it another time
but i would love to turn off the having
a mesh
uh square if you get grabbed by
infected because it sucks
oh
sure seems quiet yeah
think about how well we hide our
lookouts i know
that's what scares me
fast
look
therapy rocks
thank you chilly
they they really don't disrespect joel
it's
such a silly thing it's uh watch the
house i was laughing at the comment of a
guy who looks like neil druckmann spits
on him no they they fully don't if you
see the gameplay you'll
i'd be really surprised if anyone who
actually plays this game thinks he's
just talking
i can't even relate to it see the fedra
uniforms
he dies because he did awful [ __ ] and
they left him here
the two learning specific people very
[ __ ] angry at him in the same way
ellie's very angry at now
everyone now who she's going after we
understand why she's doing it
um but no it consistently shows
positive things about joel it wants you
to be mad
it really and you are no it's not rude
to him at all
i would i would say if anything it
almost um obsesses over him too much
uh when you get to the gate look for a
soldier named kieran tell him i sent you
then give him the kilo and he'll get you
inside the wall
kieran's [ __ ] dead dog i ain't doing
[ __ ]
cool i love drawers full of sand
what do drawers just spawn sand in the
apocalypse
why do they all have so much dust in
them
it doesn't make sense yeah no wait [ __ ]
off dina
i just wish you would leave okay you
suck don't like you
i don't want you to leave
okay get out of here um i have to climb
if i recall nope nope get out of the way
nope don't like you are these cages
i just don't remember where
holding cells you say
yeah nice jump early it wasn't that far
you could have you could have made that
so i feel like this is actually a pretty
solid segment of there being absolutely
no combat and it does have like
occasional stretches of this as you get
further in the game it gets more [ __ ]
up help me up here
more and more and more combat it's more
and more intense and more like brutal
but
yeah this is a pretty long stretch of
none maybe it's to just contrast the
absolute brutality of what happened
to the upper body strength i couldn't do
that i'll keep an eye out
just see if you can get the gate open
for me trying to for so long sounds good
all my gains are gone now i'm trying to
settle alone
uh did i find the game preaching almost
negatively said something about that
um the only way in which it is preachy
it's not preachy about any of the
relationships
it's if anything it's preachy about
it is and i can see it yeah i can't see
it is
um it's preachy about but everyone is
the bad guy
we're all bad you know you know just
different processes man but we're all
humans be bad and it does it does do
that a little bit
um but not to an extent that i find it
it's almost time you know
awful uh but it does
yeah that is the point i guess that i
feel like
they try to make occasionally
yeah there's nobody here fam
oh yep that was actually very seamless
good good shot good job
oh no worries christopher
even in the walking dead the hero
stabbed people in this yeah i think it's
unrealistic to just have your heroes be
objectively good but it's also like joel
isn't a good guy in the first game
that's like a big part of what it's
about
um so it's not like you should even
expect that you know
um
there's some stuff that i look forward
to everyone seeing and experiencing for
themselves
i think you'd have to be really stubborn
to stick to the idea that it is auntie
joel
it's just so sweet too all the time i
wonder when this was written
got a big operation coming up and i was
like one's scavenging any remaining
supplies from downtown
take any gas from the courthouse garage
to the dome it's so funny how video
gaming that's written they're like
literal experiences instructions
but you're right that is what i'm gonna
do thank you cool laptop
you watching porn
it has survived quite well
full of sand how did i guess
how did i guess
i'm on to something you know i think
i've got this [ __ ] figured out
uh did i jump ahead of myself no i
didn't this is correct
um like i said earlier they love this
minigame
they love making you a polar rope and
press triangle
this this this runs around the kaneki
stuff i actually do quite like
oh wait no i did that prematurely i have
to open this gate first that's my bad i
take it back i would like the right back
please
give me back the rope i got ahead of
there we go
oh [ __ ] oh my nails
okay
now liv good job ellie you killed it
yes i live
i don't know why she yelled to me like i
thought she'd moved hey
everything okay what was that sound i
got that gate open
gotta figure out this one now well we
believe in you
thanks it's okay ellie i've played this
before
i'm absolutely gonna [ __ ] it up i'm
gonna forget or something now
yeah oh we got it yep i already sort of
did you gotta unplug it
you gotta yeah do that
yep nice that's honestly what some of
the power blocks in my apartment i like
sometimes for no reason it is so hard
to plug things in all right let's just
run around here
and then here it is
upon replaying it i'm going to say i
think this seattle segment of this game
is too long
i think they probably could have cut it
down okay
but maybe it's that it's teaching you
all the mechanics
but i'm thinking about like how long it
takes before the next
um
put the brick away weird dude thank you
um the next time you do see joel and i
feel like it's
further away than it should be uh
huh that's it okay we need to open
this no not the journal
yeah that'll get you
yep there he is okay checkpoint get good
i think it's the main gate zero five
one two found in my copy where you can
change and tap the hold options oh thank
you accessibility alternate controls
holds and presses
thank you i will change that i won't
make everyone watch it but i appreciate
that steve thank you i
really appreciate it zero
five one two
yes done skis
oh draw full of sand get out of here
that crash was pretty loud
you love to see it
i would not stand a chance in the
apocalypse my asthma would be
off the charts just no
way now what i found a note back there
it has weird on it it says there's a wlf
safe house at some place called whip
so we find it hopefully we find our
first wlf
i'm almost writing simulator
oh [ __ ] look
maybe there is combat sooner than i
thought actually ah that
texture didn't pop in okay
let's find a way past this uh
if i remember correctly very creative
gets right to the point let's get closer
and scope it out
this does not work right right okay
right here we go i'm so bad
it's something that happens so often
oh that's right this one doesn't work
anyway forget the spoilers is it still
worth playing
yeah i think so um there's a lot of
oh gameplay the note um what the note
mentioned that there's
gas in the courthouse garage and the
dome
all right courthouse garage in the dome
so what's the plan for finding these
places we ride around and
see what we see you think tommy came
through here
but he did
yeah that rabbit oh it actually ran into
the drain pipe rather than disappearing
that's cool so
this is the huge map that you can
i have to hold it physically look at
pretty sure it's pretty cool we're here
ah nice let's mark it up as we go
i think it tells you to go straight to
the dime right so let's do that
to the death will happen out here i'm
guessing the military bombed the [ __ ]
out of this place
why would they do that it would
sometimes destroy parts of the city that
were
lost to the infected order rebels
it is uh that seems like overkill well
sometimes really cool um
having been to seattle that some of the
parts of seattle like really are
spot-on like the wolf in the aquarium
we'd line up for blocks and the food
sucked
um i'd go crazy the
convention center what packs is anyone
who's been to packs
joel has already met mr golf club
michael you are late
can you get through i don't know what's
happening with my twitch it says it's
not sending data all right
i don't know why it seems like you guys
are getting data
issue with my restream i guess
okay we got some runners here again
team don't use listen i think it makes
the game better
you can if you have trouble if you get
caught in a pickle
but generally don't do it
yeah call me a pretty thing you sweet
little thing
just come a little bit closer we have a
nice time
you want to get high don't forget to
bring a towel
convenient that that other one is just
sitting in the corner like an emo kid
what is display which are you
masturbating what's happening
i think there are more of them oh
sorry bud hey hey buddy is my bad i
don't i [ __ ] off dina you joking
[ __ ] hate you so much um okay we just
need him to like look in the other
direction
there are two runners and two clickers
now let's try and go around wide
i've played through this particular
segment multiple times because this is
where we did our fun house gameplay just
stay
just no [ __ ] oh i think i [ __ ] it
ladies and gentlemen
crap can we stab him all right
i think i got out in time if dina has
been
at all useful she hasn't brilliant
great i love having you around where is
okay he's just there
that clicker really just be do thinking
you think it's philosophizing
all right now it's not the time he saw
me
i have to make a joke okay sometimes you
gotta do what you gotta do
good
did job really that clicker was like
just you know really
just standing there thinking about life
and [ __ ]
someone tried to tell you there are no
zombies uh you can crawl in the tall
grass that was actually not
tall grass um cat can you stealth
kill clickers yes easy
the joke did cost me it's true it's fine
it's fun it's you know i feel good about
it
um i get to drink some water read some
chat for a bit
um why do people feel personally
attacked because the game's writing
didn't live up to their unfair standards
of the last game
i don't think that's what's happened
here i think what's happened here
is that people are angry at what happens
to joel
in the way that they are supposed to be
oh my god eric please leave oh he said
not watching
um but they've misdirected that anger at
the writing team
when that anger is supposed to be
directed at
abby um
yeah you're definitely supposed to be
mad about what happened for sure
that's like your whole motivating factor
from this point that is why ellie's
doing everything she's doing
so hmm
desean just said play the game [ __ ] off
day sean
all right you play the game
well i do a full playthrough probably
not no
i also like the last of us because of
the joel earlier relationship but
when pixie this game is all about the
joel ellie relationship
at least for the first like 12 hours you
see so many flashbacks
beautiful moments between the two of
them um
moments from different periods of time
yeah it is still very much about that
and obviously what's happening
here is again ellie's whole driving
force is about her relationship to joel
and how much she loves him
um despite things getting a little bit
awkward between them i mean the game
opens up with you hearing that he
[ __ ] punch someone for being mean to
her
it's very much about their relationship
it's not about
anything else flashbacks don't count i
think they do there are a lot of them
and they're really sweet
and really nice oh thank you george
heavens i appreciate that
um the game available in usa
no it is out to
midnight tonight i think yeah
good point poof of fluff everyone take
your water this water break time
you know get your drinks in now's the
time i take a water break you take a
water break
i'd be surprised if any of you have been
here the whole time though how long
we've been streaming for
two hours and 40 minutes this game
really does get into [ __ ] quick
what's the difference between a hero and
a villain take choker for example when
he killed robin it was messed up and in
joker's perspective it was right that's
what happened here
yeah that is what happened here this
game is very much about
exploring perspectives and and you are
supposed to be mad you are supposed to
be really [ __ ] angry
exactly stay hydrated drink your water
any info about multiplayer no
sorry stefan it's not it's not a loading
screen i just took a
a quick break um they said that
multiplayer is not shipping with the
game oh they needed more time or
something
it's um all right let's not [ __ ] this up
again i don't think this counts as tall
grass so i don't get the benefits of it
being tall grass
god so shiny again to anyone who's just
joining me
i woke up at five to do this i didn't
put makeup on just my morning
moisturizer
and so i'm just very sheen oh hello
um yeah multiplayer uh
i think they needed to dedicate more
time to the story so they didn't ship
with multiplayer
they said it will be coming later i
don't know if that's true
i'm curious to see if it does come later
um or if it ships as a separate game
that you have to pay for because i just
can't imagine that's gonna be very
successful
so i don't know we'll see okay i'm just
gonna i'm gonna grab you i'm gonna grab
you i'm gonna
kill you
good night sweet prince oh my god look
how [ __ ] up ellie's face just got
bye all right so now we're gonna kill
the other guy and not
uh make fun of look how funny it is
though how could uh
look at them okay look
what do you think he's thinking about
it's hard not to
why did you choose that pose for a
clicker you know
i guess this is what you get for being
team don't use the listen function
okay i feel like when i'm i'm leaning
forward you can tell how much i move
when i play video games
i think i've done my entire life i just
sort of
oh where are you going bud where you
going
what if you got stabbed in the back can
you imagine ooh i am walking a bit far
a bit fast i mean
okay no i need to kill him don't [ __ ]
around it's not worth it
but
same though both of you
stupid okay look at your [ __ ] ass
you got good hamstrings too i and then
the sick and the mouth thing happens
i think that the the click is a sort of
heart until i look at their arms
oh it really makes me feel physically
ill video game has never done that
before i don't know what it is it like
i don't know if this is a thing that
everyone has when you feel like you're
going to throw up then you get this like
taste in your mouth you start salivating
every time um yeah mr mikey
i am currently live on twitch
a lot less views on twitch than normal
though probably a lot of people are
playing the game
what percentage would you say
maybe i should answer
all right we [ __ ] did it let's get
out of here
i don't get it were still people around
they would have cleared this place out
right maybe they didn't make it to this
spot oh maybe
let's find that gas
all right ellie don't tell you to jump
on the spot you're weird dude
parts parts parts park spots this place
is a synagogue
how can you tell uh one
there are menorah decorations on the
wall it's a jewish thing
and two i didn't burst into flames just
now so burst into flames
it's just a dumb joke unlike your other
ones
you shut it thank you ellie i appreciate
it
we don't like dana this place brings
back
i really am overplaying it because i
think it's funny
i promise but also we don't [ __ ] like
dina
i don't care that's how little i care
i'm not even gonna acknowledge that you
said anything
nope nope shut up ah
i guess here we go
could it be this easy damn it could it
with a map size this large
house it's empty
that sucks now what
try our luck at the courthouse garage
let's get out of here i find dina really
boring i feel like i keep saying it yeah
cringe is you know not a word i ever
try to use very often
but uh yeah
we don't want dino oh is twitch having
problems i thought it was sorry guys
you were uh saying something yeah am i
my bit rate too high again it's so dumb
that twitch caps but
my sister used to drag me to a cinema
all the time
i don't care you still pray sometimes
really when i said when we left jackson
i said one at joel's grave sometimes i
just
say little ones to myself you see a
little price does not help
oh [ __ ] i accidentally spoke to her
helps me put things in perspective
it's a way to deal with grief
respect you know that's what i know you
know it's your life story
what's this is this game just
consistently walking and talking the
what
well these are puzzles i'm puzzle
solving scripture it's like um
like a jewish bible hmm
my sister would have flipped for this
what you said david was the one who's
the new mexico
people still dropping just false
spoilers
well james literally out of everything
i guess nobody would have finished it by
now because i've been playing for about
the amount of time that they have
but not what you said is not true um
we got fresh intel there's an active wlf
hideout on really nice handwriting
congrats on that
um on spring and fifth grab any
available soldiers in your sector and
head to the hideout asap execute any
suspect secure the location and await my
arrival sergeant
good handwriting dude
all right rope puzzles
we'd be doing look at this well i'm
going to use it to swing dina that's
what i think
that's what i think that might work
and what is it on one ellie careful
it's okay it's holding
hell yeah we swangy
i probably could have jumped off there
but you know what's life if you don't uh
swing every once in a while
nothing to it come on nina
right okay okay okay
57-74
look at this guy future look how happy
you all are
calendar
slightly less sand in hand but still
sand now i'm craving it
someone talked about world war ii so the
wheel turns and the cycle continues
tonight my family has packed our
belongings and duty or kindness will be
leaving the city escorted by your brave
men
thank you for helping me preserve what
we could of our shawl
it is difficult to leave our home behind
but in the end it is people living
people that matter you bear a heavy
burden on your shoulders and i hope
late night talks were of some comfort i
hope you got where you were going again
i really do like that they um
give character to every environment
that's cute
i don't know dude i don't know but i
don't think you should be in support of
leakers
for really any media doesn't benefit you
all them
okay rolling out oh
cynical hey across the dome off the list
let's go find the courthouse yeah it
might be worth grabbing
i really do think this part of this game
is too long especially replaying it now
this doesn't need to be as long as it is
um we are about to get into some more
combat though
ooh a bomb all right
ooh some sand i recognize that it is
supposed to be dust which is why it
makes sense but because it looks like
sand to me
i find it very funny yes please
oh i didn't realize we hadn't gotten to
that point yet i hadn't already selected
the pistol
oh that's right yeah so you you swap
apartments like that
it did take me a little while to get
used to that
okay yeah you want me to have the i got
it yeah and then what do we just wanna
we got it okay i don't know why you
maybe did that do that right now but
um shimmer
shimmer blue
very obedient horse
it's peaceful out here at least it's
weird being in a qz and not hearing
trucks
or gunfire and explosions
my sister always avoided disease that's
probably
koozies she just got more and more
paranoid
she'd sometimes wake up screaming in the
middle of the night
that's rough mm-hmm i don't know before
cool with me upgrading joel's gun
i like that she carries it i think it's
very cute
very sweet stuff okay
looks like that's everything over here
what do you got there
colin i had another room in that west
lake bank uh
hey has never been searched if that's
true then it would be so there are
supplies at some bank
pre-outbreak supplies they say we go for
it if there are enough weapons in there
i know some guys that we can trade with
the safe passage out of this hellhole
come on man you jonathan falls going
there by myself okay
do you want to take a nap let me keep it
i don't think this is the right way to
go though i feel like i'm doing the
wrong
thing but perhaps i'm not
nope i'm not okay it's combat time
this must be the music show no no they
still [ __ ] around yeah something cute in
here
imagine this place when everything was
intact
they got a bunch of records here this
got me
it's definitely got me
yeah my bad
this isn't hard i don't have any excuse
yeah twitch sorry i turned it on and off
again just to see if i can fix whatever
the issue is
what was that
nothing
well nothing so to the person who said
yeah let's play guitar instead of
chasing abby
um here's the important context of what
just happened there
yeah um joel taught her how to play
guitar
that's a song he wrote so yeah she's
still struggling with the idea that
you know joel [ __ ] died he and he
finally did the thing he promised which
is to play a guitar and
that that line i really liked that she
sings a song that he he wrote and played
for
obviously she's still thinking about
that it'd be insane not too
the rest of this is enough
i don't care about just that first bit
got me
how much you know 80 songs they sell a
music
oh the game didn't say that he wrote the
other song i just actually assumed that
he did
not this one but point was it's still
that
he told her how to play guitar and then
she played this the last song that he
played for him um
where is she
yeah i just had another song regardless
they uh you don't have a blade you
played it
which i thought was very cute
yeah it no matter what it's just very
much about
the two of them and i think also like a
lot of ellie like dealing with the grief
of losing
while also being really [ __ ] angry
she has a lot of like flashback moments
to sweet stuff
it's also i guess that last conversation
was a fight i hadn't thought about that
he should have kissed me then shut up
i wanted to me too
all right she just hated so much
it's gotten like more irrational i think
it's just
because i find it funny uh okay
but i really don't feel like they have
any chemistry i maintain that
i don't buy that ellie and dina would be
dating they seem like entirely different
humans
um okay
i think we can really just leave i could
search for stuff but i'm not calling you
i'm just going to roll out of here
nice detail there's anything else i
don't think i even had to go in there
um yeah i just circled around you can
totally skip all that
so we want to go
let's go to the door at the top shimmer
right when you need her him or her i
think it's her
right here
it's nice to have a place we call home
right yeah
when i first got to jackson i was so
overwhelmed by all the people
i was overwhelmed by all the food i
remember my first week just
hey i think i found the courthouse i
really just cut
oh well i stabbed it no it's more bad
didn't think so let's keep looking
um i don't remember how to get in
honestly
i think it might be this way
yeah stab that door does it stay it does
stay that's cool
the uh the stab mark did not fade away
two
ah yeah i feel like i remember got to
climb up here yeah
just gotta get in the building it'll be
fine don't worry about it
okay
hear it infected
uh i don't think this game destroys the
characters at all
i think people like it who cares you
know
um but yeah i think people just want to
hate this game
um no matter what definitely doesn't
destroy joel's character like not even
a little bit that's the thing i keep
saying over and over again it's the
least true thing about this
this character is very good
it's really [ __ ] sweet oh you
shouldn't be able to see me
was i noisy you're blind [ __ ]
same hair as always though she thinks
so close so gross
so gross you should have
did a rick roll no it doesn't destroy
the characters you've not played it
i finished it it totally doesn't it's
just an insane thing too
like i just feel like anyone who says i
can't finish the game
um yeah it's just it's just not even a
little bit
like it's not a matter of opinion it's
just it doesn't feel like it is i'd be
so surprised if anyone actually finishes
this game and actually um
yeah but i guess we'll see the
conversation over the next few weeks
people there are things to be mad about
and there are things to criticize i
don't think this game is 10 out of 10.
number one in no way is joel's character
ruined or destroyed okay
i think we have a runner in here also or
is it just a clicker
if yes gg easy oh no there he is
but he's just crying out there you'd
love to see it it's fine
if you could just be a little less gross
about how you sound that would be
really nice flashlight it's well-lit
we haven't killed any humans yet have we
no that
is brutal dude the clickers are thick
they have
ass
they have ass look at that flat stomach
too
that's basically impossible without
surgery so
i appreciate the money oh that was close
ass for days you're absolutely right
dusty pandas
ass for days
i agree with that liam the liam who
williams
who has said um the clicker should be
able to hear you take out other enemies
i have had that thought it does seem
like they should like you are really
quiet about it
but that's still you know you've taken a
body out you know
all right rough if you just want to stay
there you also kind of bottom-headed
i'm into it
dead um okay
i think that's everyone in here is that
it
i think so go team me too ellie let's
find my guests
me too yeah i've already been through
this i wonder what it looks like
does the combat get boring after a while
just sneaking and shooting um
isn't that really the comment of any
game
uh i found it boring no there are some
sections where i feel like there's like
more of it than is necessary into a
courthouse before
no um you're telling me you never got in
trouble back
but no it's not boring oh my god i
didn't like the combat in the first game
neverland i know a lot of people loved
it i didn't like it
i think it's way better in this game i
actually really enjoy it um
but uh yeah there are some segments that
i feel like maybe drag on a little bit
serious
but it mostly just feels that way
because it's so open
um because the environments are so open
and you know we're not using this
we don't use listen so sometimes it's
just like
that is still a thing ladies and
gentlemen you've got to tap your control
of the [ __ ] light
um
yeah you don't know like where to go so
you're killing enemies while also trying
to figure out how to navigate and that
can be a bit of
a drag but um no generally i feel like
the
amount of combat and use of it is great
eight six zero
seven two two ladies and gentlemen
this might come in handy this is a jazzy
fizzle production
cool what's it say i could have read
that that was a features banana or
something
i got gassed again ah they were losing
to the wlf i'm not talking to you
echo stop how big is this group if they
were able to beat the army
they don't damage just turn on to talk
to me about the hobbit
we need to be careful she literally said
the hobbit or the great gatsby
okay jesse uh what was the number oh no
it's on the whiteboard isn't it i have
forgotten
so quickly eight six zero seven two
two
eight
nope no it's 86 it's 86. all right my
brain is not working
did not get enough sleep 86. zero seven
zero seven two two
give me things no thank you thank you
yeah great place to hide you safe combo
you're absolutely correct but you know
when things start going wrong in the
apocalypse
sometimes you write some [ __ ] on a
board oh well actually that kind of does
make sense
no it doesn't no i guess this is where
they're confiscating things
you just why would you even have a safe
locked if you
no it doesn't make sense
benny the wlf is winning let me the
city's gonna fall any day now unless you
quit fedra i can't keep you safe so
these are different factions obviously
up until recently i could almost
understand why you stuck with them but
after all of those they market massacre
i don't see how you can call us
misguided killers with a straight face
those people were just trying to get
food for their families and today
they started banishing people for
sedition that's a death sentence listen
you still have time i can vouch for you
rust and coffee i actually know what
that is that's way later in the game
i remember seeing it unless it's a chain
or maybe it's used multiple times
you were executed sure
they weren't just executed he shot them
to pieces
maybe bullets weren't scarce yet maybe
they deserved it
i don't care let's go down they're
always a good time to go down
careful um i think i might stop soon you
guys
um i am very tired and also
work and also hungry um
but if people would like me to
i can give you the option all right i
can
hang on this combat here let me let me
talk to you guys after she's gone back
[ __ ]
i can't kill it
got the knee though okay i think there's
more
can we get them all that's gonna be too
far away just come a little bit closer
pop your head off
everybody's dead or maybe not
there is still dramatic music it's
another [ __ ] clip
no no no no no where you going it's
harder to monitor you when you're uh
okay
uh okay i think that's it
that seems like it might be jesus um
okay so i was going to say
i could stream off the work
today from this exact point
um i could just pick up where we leave
off to continue this playthrough today
gasoline or don't you
i have a save file that is exactly at
the point where you start playing as
abby the [ __ ] federer gate is calling
that i intentionally kept
which of those would people prefer also
naturally please only answer if you'll
actually come back but i could do that
later tonight
either continue this or jump from
literally halfway through to show you
what that
stuff is here seems like majority people
are saying here
all right we can do it um
i don't know that i'll finish this
because i don't know that i want to play
through the whole thing again yeah
literally everyone's saying here
oh i can do that i can do that but that
works for me
oh yeah it is this roller door this this
is what this is where i'm supposed to go
is it not it's just five minutes
coming make yourself useful dina
so let me just get this gas back to
where i'm supposed to get this gas back
to
and then i will wrap it up in the
morning
okay let go uh yeah by the time that i
start playing
again after work
that would be also uh funhouse will be
streaming out ea play reactions today
could be a while before it'll be
probably around
6 p.m it might be worth grabbing some
supplies on
good point i disagree
i don't need supplies
shut up so we go
uh then down and then back to the gate i
think this shouldn't be that hot are you
doing back there
this one homesick a little bit you
that's just straight down and then out
it's having a roof over my head
you know i've always dreamed of
fixing up a farm just outside of jackson
why wouldn't you stay walking cliche i
don't know
i like your hair we're gonna want to
turn sounds lonely
only if you're doing it alone oh this
way
so are we getting serious though raise
sheep and milk cows
are you making fun of me
no that actually sounds
kind of nice really isn't it also like
kind of your only option though really
like it it does sound nice i'll give you
that in the apocalypse but also what
else are you gonna do
other than start a farm i think that's
like literally the whole thing
ah that was an adventure
i haven't found any of them yet hey
it's a big city we barely started
looking
all right let's just get through this
gate because that is at least the end of
this
particular objective
gotta fuel her up
right and then get through the gate
there there is combat right after this i
think here we go
this is first human combat so maybe i'm
gonna keep adding time this game is very
easy to
play a lot of in a single sitting like
it is difficult to put down
i got it um and i am a combat snob
which means
this game is never going to be raiders
are pretty finicky
game of the year for me
nothing last year it was sakura from the
year before it was god of war
very different things um but it is hard
to put this game down
uh it is gate codes
this is eastgate
five three four five i think that's what
it is or is it rubbed off
there are one of one of them is yeah one
of them is rubbed off
five oh three
four
it worked so [ __ ] did love
no welcome or they're just waiting for
us
i let's look for a way in i'm gonna stop
here
which means that if i do pick up tonight
from this exact same spot
um yeah it's combat like right up the
hill
you love a good combat right up the hill
oh thank you everyone for joining me
i think this is potentially the most uh
concurrence i've had on youtube i'm not
sure but uh very excited for ea play
um which i never say i'm never excited
for ea press conferences
thank you adam i appreciate it uh this
stream is gonna be kept online yeah
usually i don't leave them up but i am
gonna leave this one up
i'll stream later um yeah we'll also be
live
on fun house with our reactions of the
ea conference i hope that they
give us like mass effect or skate um
seems unlikely where skaters could sir
but it would be cool
um my brain's really not working because
i got up too early so i'm actually going
to take a nap
i have to write inside gaming at 8 30
though oh [ __ ] i got it right inside
gaming right now
so i'm going to do that and then i'm
going to take a nap and then i have to
work
ea conference is
let me check the time
it starts at
four pacific time four to five so yeah
i'll stream like an hour after that
man today's gonna suck it's gonna be a
rough day you guys i got it i got it in
for me
but we'll do our best thank you all for
watching um
brianna this is the start of the game
well okay i'm however long i've been
streaming for is however long we are in
which is apparently
uh three hours so this is three hours in
and uh no adam
i am going to just start off from here
again rather than
i'll probably go up to the end of the
first half today yeah we'll see how i
feel tonight i'll probably be exhausted
but yeah we'll see
so have a good day everyone thank you
for joining me um
i will see you guys tonight i'll post on
twitter or whatever if i decide not to
do it because i'm like way too tired or
something it's gonna be a big day
but um that's the plan i plan to so
uh love you all i also have a spoiler
cast coming with uh i'm very excited
next monday hoping to do it live i have
two journalists who gave it a 10
two journalists who say they would have
given it like a five and i'm basically
going to have those teams
explain their perspectives on this game
and why they're so different because
they're
very passionate people i'm really
excited and i fit right in the middle of
those two so it's going to be super fun
that should be up next week
podcast goes up tomorrow with troy we
talk a little bit about the game but
mostly about
how devs feel about review scores
actually so yep i will see you guys
later
thank you for joining me